There are many people who say that if you want to learn practical Japanese, you shouldn't use anime to
study,
but I personally
don't think anime is as practical as teaching materials.
What were you doing before?
Yes, you used Twitter,
so you're going to check Instagram after this.  It's being
used, isn't it?
Serial
Experiments Rain
is definitely more practical than Genki. Now that AI is
spreading, the next thing that's said to spread
is VR.  If you do, you'll have an AI girlfriend."
No, it'll be a certainty, so
Chobits is more useful than Japaneseypeople. Also, Saori
's
romantic girlfriend will eventually
integrate with the Internet's general artificial intelligence and you.  But
when you don't know how to deal with it,
of course the
Ghost in the Shell is more helpful than the door.
Using it
should lead to more practical Japanese
By the way, if you already spend part of your life in the Metaverse, it
seems that SAO will be useful, but I
wouldn't really recommend it.